welcome back can Joe Biden the Democrats
presumptive nominee for president bring
his party together in time for the
November election the former VP is doing
his best to woo Bernie Sanders
supporters now that Sanders has gotten
out or suspended his campaign what we
see now is that Biden is coming out with
a plan to expand Medicare eligibility
and secondly to forgive some student
loan debts both ideas put forward by
Sanders Biden says he'll do these things
if he's elected president and Biden
better act quickly because a new poll
from Fox News shows President Trump
virtually tied with Biden at 42% support
a piece Jessie let me come to you and
ask given what Joe Biden is doing is a
little bit of a surprise to me cuz
politicians after the primaries they
usually move to the center but now we
see Joe Biden moving to the left how do
you interpret this
I think it's weak and I think you're
dead on one I think this is too late
Bernie Bros won a revolution and
anything short of a revolution is just
not gonna be good enough for the Bernie
bros you saw Bernie on stage anybody to
the right of Bernie he basically said
was like a capitalist Pig that was you
know business as usual so I don't think
it's gonna do Biden any good to flirt
with the Bernie bros or make these types
of overtures they have a big problem his
base is cracked he's probably going to
lose maybe 10 to 15 percent of the
Bernie Bros and the fact that a Fox News
poll which hasn't been that favorable to
president Trump has the president tied
with Joe Biden this far out in a
presidential election I think it's very
good news for the president Greg is
there anything anything that Joe Biden
can do to really pull in the Bernie bros
because the hardcore support is not I
think a lot of people are not
necessarily hardcore on the Bernie side
but let's talk about the hardcore folks
what could Joe Biden do to say to them
jump on the bandwagon he should wear a
burny mask because that's kind of what
he's doing right now if I if I were
Trump I would say Joe's just a Bernie in
a Joe mask and then and then say like do
you remember April in March 2020 we had
lines for food empty shelves high
unemployment that's the Democratic Party
because that's how socialism looks you
got a taste for it that's what you're
gonna get if you elect Joe Hey but but
but anyway because it's your birthday
one I have I have a special talking
point especially for you
the big prohibition the big problem with
Joe is that he could not pull off a
presser like today
Trump's brain is especially agile and
Swift and capable and when you watch
that you put Joe in that place and you
know that he gets easily frustrated over
simple sentences so here's my talking
point the question on everyone's mind
right now is could president Trump be
the most caring president we've ever had
in the history of the country because
the evidence is clear he is willing to
put his economic achievements in
jeopardy to save lives he's willing to
bankrupt his own business to save lives
he's willing to lose reelection to save
lives put that on top of his revulsion
over military intervention and his deep
desire to get troops out of harm's way
this guy makes Florence Nightingale look
like Lizzie Borden that's my birth date
talking point two one Wow on top of the
cake yeah really I was too sweet my
mother can only eat so much I wrote
after you wand I wrote it for you cuz I
knew you would love it I appreciate it
it was it's it's so rich and so rich you
know so Dana
one of the one of the things that we
talk about here is you know the
president has clearly been trying to
foment the fighting the kind of internal
dissension among Democrats but I just
think to myself if you're on the that on
the Joe Biden camp and you say to the
Biden's to the Bernie Sanders supporters
who do you want to replace Ruth Bader
Ginsburg well I just shocked them and
say up sorry I was just playing around
of course I'm gonna vote and for Joe
Biden well president Trump is not just a
commander in chief and the decider in
chief he's the instigator in chief and
he's really good at it like Jesse was
saying yesterday how he used to do at
the lunch table and get people to fight
I mean it's all it's good to get your
really that's really good but here you
know to the victors should go the spoils
but that's only for a confident
Conqueror and Joe Biden is a weak
nominee he's hobbled and now he's in the
middle of trying to deal with this
during a pandemic and instead of being
victorious and as you said like moved to
the center say I can be the president
for all Americans he's putting out
policy proposals that probably would
have helped him in New Hampshire primary
not now and I don't understand what
their strategy is maybe they'll come out
one day and try to tell us well Emily I
mean I think that the strategy is
emerging I think they do would you give
these folks time because I think that
there's a political process taking place
in which Biden is slowly trying to not
only woo some of Sanders supporters but
Woo's Sanders himself is that a fair
assessment it might be and I think the
question is whether he has enough time
to work this miracle and you know I
think short of ventriloquism this
delicate balancing act is not going to
work I don't think he can have it both
ways and what I mean by that is right
now we see him capitulating to those
Bernie brows right he's talking about
climate policy income inequality college
and university tuition forgiveness all
of that stuff that they love but at the
same time he can't have his cake and eat
it too with the independents and the
moderates that he needs to actually win
the general election and so moving
forward he needs to make that call as
what would actually benefit him because
at the end of the day as Jesse pointed
out those Bernie bros care about
authenticity so if he chooses another
establishment VP candidate and then
thinks that just by talking that talk he
will
have them on his side he'll be sorely
disappointed